كشفت وزاره الداخليه السعوديه العربيه عن
توفير منصه ابشر لسبعه عشر مليار ريال
سنويا من خلال الاستغناء عن الخدمات
الحكوميه التقليديه وفق للمتحدث باسمي
منصه ابشر طارق جلال حميد وكانت وزاره
الداخليه السعوديه اعلنت عن تدشين منصه
ابشر الالكترونيه ل 10 خدمات جديده من
اهمها خدمه الابلاغ عن سرقه السيارات
وتجديد الجواز السعودي واستعراض الهويه
رقميا بالاضافه الى خدمه التحقق من
امكانيه الخروج عبر المنافذ البريه
السنه هذه في منطقه ابشر 22 تم اطلاق
مجموعه من الخدمات الجديده من مختلف
القطاعات من اهمها خدمات الهويه الرقميه
بشكلها الجديد ايضا خدمه التحقق من هذا
الهويه الرقميه مقدمه الى القطاع الخاص
والجهات الحكوميه لكذلك لدينا خدمه ابشر
سفر وهي مقدمه للراقبين
بالخروج من المنافذ البريه
وكذلك لدينا او تم اطلاق خدمات الابلاغ عن
المركبات المسروقه تقدمها المديريه العامه
للامن العام وخدمات الجواز الجزء السعودي
الاصدار والتجديد للجواز الجديده والجواز
الالكترونيه اللي تقدمها المديريه العامه
للجوازات الحقيقه وسط اقتصادي فقط ابشر
الاكثر من 17 اكثر من مليار ريال سنويا
كوفر على الاقتصاد السعودي سواء على مقدم
الخدمه او على المستفيد من الخدمه او على
الاقتصاد والبنيه التحتيه بشكل عام
فالحقيقه لدينا مجموعه من الاحصائيات
الرائعه تكلم سنويا عندنا مليونين همم
خدمه همم او مليون العمليه شهريا همم تنفذ
اجرائيه همم تم تقديم اكثر من 380 خدمه
عبر المناصه همم عدد العملاء يقترب من 27
مليون هويه رقميه طبعا هؤلاء العملاء
يستخدمه من رسم تبشر ويستخدمون ايضا
المنصات الاخرى عبرى النفاذ الوطني الموحد
معنا من الرياض والمتحدث باسم منصه ابشر
طارق بن حميد
طارق حياك الله معي في نشرته الرابعه انا
ودي بس توضح لنا همم اكثر 17 مليار ريال
مبلغ كبير جدا يعني كيف تمكنت منصه ابشر
من توفير هذا المبلغ
حياك الله و شكرا لكم على استضافه في
البدايه طبعا الدراسه اللي تمت على منصه
ابشر الحقيقه من ناحيه الوكر الاقتصاديه
هي طبعا من عده جوانب الجانب الاقتصادي
الجانب الامني البيئي والاجتماعي كذلك لكن
احنا نبغى نركز على الجانب الاقتصادي
الوفره من حسابه على ثلاث جهات او ثلاث
اطراف الطرف المستفيد اللي هو مقدم او
المستفيد من الخدمه الفرد وايضا الشركات
الخاصه همم الطرف الاخر اللي هو مقدم
الخدمه القطاعات وزاره الداخليه
والطرف الثالث اللي هو الاقتصاد البنيه
التحتيه كل ما يتعلق في الامور
الادوات التي يمكن استخدامها وفي المتاحه
للجميع الجميع
تم احتساب الوفر من كل زاويه باختلاف طبعا
همم
المعادلات التي تم اختراعه ايضا
الاحترابات وخرجنا بهذا المبلغ اللي نجد
انه الى حد كبير يعتبر متحفظ قد يكون
الاثر اقتصاديا يعني المبلغ الحقيقي ممكن
يكون اكثر من كده همم
تم اخذ الاضطرابات يعني الاعتبار وتم اخذ
المعادلات يعني اعتبار هذا الذي نعرفه ان
احنا متاكدين منه مثلا سعر تقديم الخدمه
او تكلفه التقديم الخدمه التقليديين عبر
المكان هذا يمكن احتساب بكل بساطه واحتساب
التكاليف مقابل عدد القائمه المقدمه لكن
في امور اخرى قد تكون يعني من الصعب همم
ومن الصعب تحويل له الى قيمه همم رقميه
فبالتالي نعتقد انه بدون اخذ هذه
المعايير او هذه الاعتبارات همم في عين
همم
نعتقد انه المبلغ يكون اكثر من ذلك اليوم
كمان المنصه قال لنا تعال شيء همم خدمات
جديده او 10 خدمات همم جديده لفت نظري
موضوع الابلاغ عن سرقه السيارات لكن هذه
من اكثر المشاكل اللي كان نتواجه السعوديه
انه يتجه الى مقر الشرطه همم وبعد كده
يعني المواطن نفسه هو اللي يروح يبحث عن
سيارته يعني في في كثير من الاحوال ايش
اللي بيتغير بعد تقديم الشخص او يبلغ عن
سرقه سيارته من خلال منصه ابشر طبعا
الخدمه المقدمه عن طريق ابشر هي فقط فيما
يتعلق
بمعنى سابقا كان من المفروض الشخص اللي
همم يعني تعرضت له السرقه او لو حته حتى
لوحه المركبه للسرقه يعني يجب ان يتوجه
لمراكز الان نستطيع انه يرفع البلاغ عن
طريق ابشر بس تقوم همم يعني الجهات
المختصه في المدير العام الامن العام
لمعالجه هذا البلاء
وايضا يمكن للمستفيد يعني الرجوع الى
المنصه الى ابشر ويتحقق من التحديثات هذا
باختصار الخدمه المقدمه عن طريق مدرسه
ابشر حاليا اهم الخدمات الجديده ايضا وهل
هناك نيه للتوسع فيها
وسؤال اخر من زاويه اخرى انت تعرف انه
يعني موضوع ابشر كان مثيل للجدل وخاصه في
نظره الخارج لهذه المنصه واتهامات بانه
هذه يستخدم للتجسس على الناس وغيرها من
الامور كيف يعني تدافعون على هذه المنصه
او تردون على مثل هذه
الخدمات الخدمات الجديده التي اطلقت
باختصار خدمات همم الهويه الرقميه بشكلها
الجديد كذلك خدمات تتيح للجهاز التحقق من
هذه الهويه الرقميه وتحكم من موسيقيتها
كذلك فيما يتعلق ايضا بالهويه الرقميه
احنا للمقيمين همم الاطلاع او استعراض
وثائق الرقميه للتابعين همم لهم همم خدمه
البلاغ عن همم المركبات المسروقه ايضا
خدمات او ما وصلنا الى مرحله همم في تجديد
واصدار الجواز تراني بشكل كامل اللي هو
الجواز الجديد مقدم المديريه العامه
للجوازات ايضا خدمه همم
المدفوعات الحكوميه والرسوم الحكوميه
لخدمات الداخليه عبر منصه تاشيره فيما
يتعلق طبعا ايش المستقبل يعني ناقصه ابشر
كانت وما زالت وستظل همم الممكن القناه
الرقميه لوزاره الداخليه في مشاريها وفي
مشروع الرقبه فيما يتعلق همم
الاتهامات السابقه التي وصلت فيها المنصه
طبعا الموضوع هذا مخفي فيه وكانت يعني
مبني على
موضوعنا احنا سابقا يعني في وقتها للاعلام
ووضحنا ايضا بالشركات المقدمه لمتاجر
التطبيقات انه تطبيق ابشر لا يستخدمه
ااا يعني خاصيه التتبع اساسا وفي النهايه
هي فقط منصه ابشر هي منصه لتقديم يعني
يعني الخدمه تقدم يدويا في المكاتب الان
اصبحت تقدم للمستفيد في مكانه لا اكثر ولا
اقل وطبعا كانت يعني كل الادعاءات في
وقتنا كانت غير صحيحه وتم الرد عليها هذه
حينها والا الحمد والامانه المنصه رايحات
الكثير من الناس في حياتهم اليوميه يعني
الحمد لله